these are some of the drinks in my
fridge guys just some of them sub that
we drink along water and many other
things many fruits to pick from many
foods to eat from Subhan Allah what
about the people who are starving in
Gaza all around the world who do not
have food to eat how can we make these
drinks these foods go down our throat
knowing that they're starving I am
working with one charity for the food
project guys and they are 100% donation
policy charity I know the brothers who
run the charity and I have full trust
inam brothers and sisters and dear
friends I couldn't believe it when I
heard this but to be honest I'm not
really sure Morocco let an Israeli ship
to dock replenish re-energize to go and
commit a genocide for some odat reason
Spain refused Spain refused A catheric
Country yes you know we Muslims we like
to you know sometimes you know oh this
kuf and this this that look Subhan Allah
you know in the sight of Allah subhana
tala of course a Believer yes the worst
of a Believer is better than the best of
a disbeliever when it comes to what
because we acknowledge God Almighty yes
because servitude and acknowledging him
and worship alone comes before
everything and doing that because this
whole universe belongs to Allah that
comes above everything and somebody who
does that is better than many people
that don't do that for whoever they are
for that reason however tells us that
when it comes to this a kufar country
who rules by Justice Allah will give
them a victory over a Muslim country
that does not rule by justice justice is
what the greatest Injustice on this
Earth is shik a social importance to
Allah subh so that's why Justice is very
very a in the sight of Allah subh tala
and that's why Allah has negated
oppression to himself and has told us
not to oppress one another how could it
be that a Muslim country Morocco allows
this genocidal ship of these genocides
these murderers these baby killers on
that ship to come and replenish and
re-energize while Spain has rejected a
cfir country tells you a lot about the
Muslim M and this comes to what a matter
of lack of
the Muslim world is so inferior they
think that success is with the riches so
they are following the Western system
they're thinking that's the only way if
we allow alcohol gambling sex before
marriage you know all this kind of stuff
you know the Western systems whatever
you know this is how we will succeed
that's what they're doing they are
literally saying we do not have enough
trust or we don't have trust in the
promise of Allah we're going to take the
matters into our own hands do the Haram
and succeed you are going to lose this
life and the Hereafter mark my words
going to lose this life and the
Hereafter aldah at least the disbeliever
has some kind of something that he
relies on even if there's no God if it's
liberal country if it's an atheist
country they don't even believe in God
you know they just think this is just
wrong the moral what Allah has created
them their Mercy is coming out and
saying No this is wrong whereas the
Muslim world is saying no no no we have
interests those interests come before
our principles and come before what
Allah has legislated and whichever
country it is not Morocco turkey
whichever country it is may Allah
subhana wa ta'ala never let let them
succeed if their goal is this and they
just care about you know the worldly
Affairs Etc let them never succeed
because the video that you saw of the
Moroccans protesting because it's not
this a Moroccan country the government
we're not talking about the Moroccans
aldah the Moroccans you know they
they're they're clear they we their
allegiance and their trust is clear
alhamdulillah you can see with the
protest may Allah bless and preserve
them the point is not that the point is
Subhan Allah that these governments subh
we need to take them to account again
like I said before with this I am not
asking for like not that my words are
going to mean anything Rebellion Etc cuz
we're against that that caus more them
good but sadly as you can see we need to
speak out against this that's all I
wanted to say brother and sisters may
Allah subh T keep our brothers firm
inshallah and history will remember
those who were on the side of
Palestinians even if they were
disbelievers Subhan Allah may Allah
bless you guys